(cop show music)
- [Radio] Car 67,
come in car 67.
- This is car 67,
- we're code five,
- code five,
- nothing to report.
- we've got nothing to report.
- You are such an idiot
man, I mean Van Hagar
had just as many hits as the
original Van Halen, okay.
5150, Best of Both
Worlds, When It's Love,
Dreams, Summer Nights,
Finish What Ya Started,
Black and Blue, Right Now--
- [Radio] Right Now, really,
you're gonna come at me
with Right Now, please.
- What are you talking
about, Right Now
was the theme of an
entire generation.
- [Radio] It was a Pepsi
jingle, you mental case.
- Have you not
listened to the poetry,
the genius, of Sammy
Hagar's lyrics,
talking about
living for the day,
taking advantage of what
you have, right now,
don't wait 'til
tomorrow with Theresa?
- [Radio] Theresa, did
you just say Theresa?
- No, I didn't.
- Holy shit,
you just put your ex wife
into a Van Hagar song.
- I did not.
- [Radio] Oh my god.
- [Radio] What fucking
asshole does that?
- No I didn't, no don't
tell the guys over.
Tell the guys to mind
their own business.
You mind your own business Hawk,
you leave Sammy
Hagar, you stop it!
You stop it right now,
(laughing over radio)
stop it, you stop it.
Die in a car fire, you jackass!
Stop, dack, dah!
- So, something
bugging you, or...
- Yeah, something's bugging me,
you don't talk shit
about Right Now, on my--
- I'm gonna fuck
this car, ha ha.
Hey, hey.
- It's Captain Ed.
Captain Ed U Cation.
- Watch me fuck this car,
it's as easy as one, two, three,
oh yeah, that's it, that's it.
- Why is Sergeant
Pepper humping our car?
- Come on, there's no way
you don't know who that is.
He's got this great
show for kids,
that makes learning
fun, and hip.
He's great, Captain Ed!
- [Captain Ed]
Drink my piss, car.
- Ha, classic Captain Ed.
- This is our car, asshole!
I don't care how many
kids he's educated,
I'm taking this guy in.
- Come on, he's
just goofing around.
- Typical Hollywood
bullshit, he thinks just
because he's a celebrity,
he can do whatever he wants,
he can fuck my wife and
I'm just gonna stand around
and take it, get over here.
- Excuse me sir, big fan.
Could I trouble you
for some ID please?
- Why do you need
to see some ID huh,
you obviously know
who he is, fanboy.
- Well I doubt his real
name is Captain Ed U Cation,
oh, wow, it's really
Captain Ed U Cation.
- I got it legally changed.
- Can you even change your
name to Captain legally?
- No, I actually am a captain.
You two wanna get
married, I can do it,
but all we gotta do
is find an ocean.
You and I should have
an underwear party.
- Why did you do that?
- He rushed me!
- It's just his way,
he's a goofy guy.
And he uses that goofiness,
to fight illiteracy.
So just give him a break,
he's just having a bad day.
- I'm having the best day.
(puking)
- Seriously?
Typical Hollywood celebrity,
does whatever he wants,
puke on my shoe, no
problem, make a mistake,
it's okay, live your life
with no responsibilities,
right Captain?
You are an idol to
children for God's sakes.
- That's true, my kids
really look up to him.
He's their hero.
I'm not, but they love him.
- Doesn't that piss you off?
You spent your whole life
trying to be a good cop,
and this Hollywood fly-by-night
can do whatever he wants,
he's worshiped like a god, I
mean you're getting shot at,
and he's taking my
wife out to dinner,
and doing the hibbidy-dibbidy.
- Okay, I feel like
I need to make sure
you know Captain Ed
isn't the weatherman
your wife left you for.
- Uh, ex wife, and yes, I
know, I'm not some kinda--
- Give me that dick.
I'm gonna make ya feel
like a special boy.
- Wow, it's been awhile since
anyone made me feel special,
but, um, I'm gonna have
to decline, I'm married.
- I got a gun in here somewhere.
- No way does he have a gun.
- I'm pretty sure
it's, there it is.
- He's got a gun.
- I was wrong,
I was wrong.
(gunshot)
Okay, so we definitely
have to take this guy in.
- Gee, do ya think so?
- Yes.
Normally I wouldn't ask, and
I know it's not procedure,
but do you think we can get
a picture with Captain Ed?
It would go a long
way with the kids.
- You wanna take a
picture with him?
Seriously?
- Yes.
- Now come to think of it, if
my wife wants to screw me over
by fucking a weatherman,
I'll get revenge on her
by fucking a kid's show host.
- Yeah, that makes sense, okay,
let's take like a
selfie, let's do--
- It's actually called an ussie.
- Really?
- Yeah, like if there's
more than one person,
it's called an ussie now.
- Oh, okay.
Uh, cheese!
That's good, that's real good.
Now, hey, pretend
you're an urban youth,
and he's teaching
you how to read.
Cheese!
Alright, now get back to--
- [Chance] No no,
let me teabag him.
- [Moses] No, Captain
Ed, Captain Ed?
- What's wrong with him?
- He's not breathing.
He's not breathing,
Captain Ed, Captain Ed!
- Wake him up.
- No, come on!
Gah, wake up!
He's not waking up.
Okay, you know he's
beloved by millions, right?
Captain Ed, come on if you
die my kids will hate me!
Please wake up.
- Okay, woah woah, calm down,
I got an idea, I got an idea.
Get in the car, just go, go,
come on, come on, come on.
(body sliding down hood)
You know, Right Now
really is a good song.
- [Moses] Is that Van
Halen or Van Hagar?
- [Chance] Shut up.